bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
petite vidéo où on va rigoler on va
rigoler par toutatis
parce qu'on va parler aujourd'hui de
notre dinosaures préféré le
tyrannosaurus rex et on va surtout
parler d'une vidéo sur notre dinosaures
préféré vidéo qui s'intitule le top 5
des espèces de t-rex les plus
terrifiantes de l'histoire alors
j'aurais voulu en faire un des bonnes kg
pénitence le truc c'est que j'ai
tellement ri en voyant cette vidéo que
du coup ça qualifie pas à des bonnes kg
pénitence des bonnes kg pénitence il
faut que je déteste ce que je regarde
cette vidéo je les ai adorés
je les aimais mais tellement cette vidéo
elle est parfaite elle est parfaite et
déjà rien que sur le titre et la
vignette vous pouvez voir à quel point
on atteint la perfection regarder on
peut jouer au jeu des 7 erreurs bon en
réalité y en a bien plus que certain des
erreurs mais c'est tellement beau c'est
tellement beau à ce niveau là que ça en
devient artistique alors déjà c'est une
vidéo qui prétend parler de tyrannosaure
qu'est ce qu'on a sur la vignette le
cératosaure de jurassic park 3 donc je
vais vous montrer
serra do zaurus jurassic park iii voilà
c'est lui aucun doute sur
l'identification donc déjà ça commence
bien encore la vignette te promet quand
le titre ii promet du tyrannosaure et
que la vignette peuvant à cératosaure
déjà tu sais que tu es tu sais que tu
vas être bien accueillie tu sais qu'on
est dans 30 he de bonnes mains puis et
puis bon voilà il ya des vidéos de la
même chaîne en dessous les vignettes
sont pas mal aussi un là là on a quand
même le
le spin au predator jeu c'est pas un
truc à moitié spinosaures à moitié
predator donc les cinq espèces de
spinosaures les plus terrifiantes de
l'histoire c'est sûr que avec un truc
comme ça ça va être terrifiant et c'est
clair là vous avez les ennemis mortels
du tyrannosaure je ne sais pas ce que
c'est que cette chose moitié
tyrannosaure moitié porc-épic mais ça a
l'air assez assez épicé aussi donc voilà
on sent qu'on va s'amuser en regardant
cette vidéo alors on peut on peut ne
serait-ce que déjà commencé à
décortiquer le titre parce qu'il n'ya
pas que la vignette qui est anthologique
le titre aussi top 5 des espèces de
t-rex alors des espèces de t-rex bon on
va passer on va passer sur le fait que
t-rex ça s'écrit pas comme ça il n'y a
qu'une seule manière d'écrire t-rex et
là je m'adresse à tout le monde
il ya une seule manière d'écrire t-rex
t-rex c'est l'abréviation de
tyrannosaurus rex
on se permet d'abréger le tyrannosaurus
en fait avec un thé c'est un truc c'est
une convention d'écriture en taxonomie
donc la science de la classification
donc c'est pas un truc qui sort de nulle
part la taxonomie c'est un des trucs qui
a le plus de règles au monde
voilà c'est extrêmement précis la
taxonomie est donc quand on dit t-rex on
abreu ont fait une abréviation de
tyrannosaurus rex d'une elle doit être
en italique cette abréviation donc t-rex
en en italique et al derrière le thé
c'est un point donc t-rex retenez le
bien ça ne s'écrit que d'une seule façon
ça s'écrit thé point espace rex en
italique et ya qu une seule situation
dans laquelle vous n'écrirez pas t-rex
en italique sait si vous l'écrivez à la
main et lorsqu'à la faudra le souligner
pour bien montrer qu'il s'agit d'un nom
d'espèce et pas de n'importe quel mot
balancer comme ça donc déjà t-rex il ya
une erreur ça ne s'écrit pas avec un
tiret ça s'écrit avec un point mais des
espèces de t-rex là c'est formidable il
ya des espèces de t-rex alors c'est
comme si vous disiez top 5 des espèces
d'homo sapiens c'est pareil c'est pareil
vous vous sentez un petit bond il ya un
petit relent de racisme évidemment
derrière le fait de dire qu'il ya
différentes espèces d'homo sapiens mais
en gros c'est le même
c'est la même gêne ans si vous voulez
quand on dit cinq espèces de t-rex t-rex
c'est une espèce homo sapiens c'est une
espèce
voilà si vous dites diplodocus
diplodocus il ya plusieurs espèces oui
c'est pas parce que c'est un dinosaure
qui a forcément qu'une espèce un jeu
d'hier s'est pas passé un problème mais
diplodocus c'est le nom de genre comme
tyrannosaurus mon tyrannosaurus a ceci
de particulier que contrairement à
diplodocus il n'y a pas plusieurs
espèces dans le genre tyrannosaurus y en
a qu'une et c'est tyrannosaurus rex rex
c'est le nom d'espèce donc vous pouvez
voir ça comme un prénom et un nom de
famille
voilà sauf qu'en fait c'est le nom de
famille qui vient en premier
en gros c'est juste ça donc
tyrannosaurus c'est son nom de famille
et rex c'est son petit prénom donc il
peut pas y avoir plusieurs espèces de
t-rex il n'y a qu'une seule espèce de
t-rex et c'est t-rex et c'est tout donc
dire qu'il ya cinq espèces de t-rex déjà
il ya du non sens dans l'air c'est
magnifique
d'ailleurs puisqu'on parle de tirek
cette classification on pourrait
s'imaginer que dire t-rex dire qu'il
n'ya pas plusieurs espèces de t-rex
c'est pinailler on comprend très bien ce
qui veut dire il veut parler de la
famille des tyrannosaures en général oui
mais non c'est pas pinailler de dire que
t-rex c'est pas les tyrannosaures c'est
pas pinailler du tout alors je vais vous
montrer un petit arbre phylogénétique
des tyrannosaures arbres phylogénétiques
qui a été publiée dans la revue
scientific report donc la phylogénie et
l'histoire évolutive des tyrannosaures
aux ide et vous allez voir que parler de
t-rex pour parler de tyrannosaure en
général et même parler de tyrannosaure
en général c'est une erreur donc
tyrannosaurus et la voilà c'est une
toute petite branche au milieu d'un
grand arbre évolutif des tyrannosaures
aux ide et le truc c'est quand vous
dites tyrannosaure vous pouvez tout
aussi bien faire référence à
tyrannosaurus parce que tyrannosaurus
francisé s'adonne tyrannosaure donc
parce que tyrannosaurus s'est jamais du
latin je veux dire donc si vous le
franciser ça devient tyrannosaure la
tarbes aux russes ici si vous le
franciser ça devient tarbes aux hordes
asplet taurus ça devient d'aspe tozeur
donc voilà donc tyrannosaure ça peut
être le genre tyrannosaurus francisé
donc quand vous dites tyrannosaure vous
pouvez tout aussi bien faire référence à
tyrannosaurus rex
puis ce jeu puisque je le rappelle
tyrannosaurus rex est la seule espèce de
tyrannosaurus donc dia tyrannosaure peut
vouloir dire tyrannosaurus oui mais oui
mais dire tyrannosaure peut aussi
vouloir dire les tyrannosaures ine les
tyrannosaures in et hop je vais zoom et
on va jouer un petit peu sur cette image
voilà les tyrannosaures inné c'est le
petit mot que vous voyez là
les tyrannosaures inné c'est un ensemble
de genre et d'espèces qui sont proches
de tyrannosaurus mais qui ne sont pas
tyrannosaurus donc dire tyrannosaure ça
peut faire référence aux tyrannosaures
inné dire tyrannosaure ça peut aussi
faire référence e tyrannosauridés des
tyrannosauridés c'est en gros les
tyrannosaures qui ont des petits bras
vous pouvez voir sur les images
albertosaurus il est tyrannosaures et
tout ce qui rentre les deux ils ont tous
des petits bras alors que ce qui à
l'extérieur comme dreams aux russes
voyez qu'il a des grands bras donc les
tyrannosaures avait primitivement des
grands bras mais ben voilà les
tyrannosauridés ce sont les
tyrannosaures aux ide à petit brun et
donc quand vous dites tyrannosaure ça
peut tout aussi bien faire référence à
tyrannosauridés et il ya des gens qui
font référence aux tyrannosauridés en
parlant de tyrannosaure aux ide
ce que vous voyez écrit la outils ou ici
par exemple tyrannosaure aux ide
les tyrannosaures aux idées assez la
grande famille qui contient
tyrannosaurus et tous ses proches
parents donc parler de tyrannosaure ça
peut aussi bien faire référence aux
tyrannosaures aux ide c'est à dire à
toutes ces espèces là y compris des
machins qui ressemble pas du tout à un
tyrannosaure comme you tyrannus vous
voyez là il a cette espèce de crête sur
le nez ou guan longue qui était tout
petit et complètement recouvert de
plumes
ça peut faire référence aux
tyrannosauridés c'est à dire tous les
tyrannosaures oïda petit bras ou ça peut
faire référence e tyrannosauridés c'est
à dire cette toute petite famille à
l'intérieur de la grande famille des
tyrannosaures aux ide
donc c'est pas anodin de d'utiliser le
mauvais termes taxonomique comme le fait
de
le titre de cette vidéo c'est pas du
tout anodin en réalité ce dont il va
nous parler dans cette vidéo ce sont bel
et bien des tyrannosaures aux ide et pas
de t-rex seulement donc voilà je ne
supporte pas contrairement à ce que vous
pourriez dire je ne supporte pas c'est
important c'est important parce que des
fois on va on va avoir des cas comme des
cas extrêmes de mauvaises
interprétations du mot t-rex par exemple
ici donc on nous parle de t-rex à 1
découverte d'une nouvelle espèce de
dinosaure lointain cousin du t-rex alors
t-rex devrait être en italique mais au
moins ils ont mis un point donc
par contre ils ont mis de majuscule à
rex rex ne prend pas de majuscule
là il faut remercier la mise en forme
automatique qui après un pointe mais
forcément une majuscule je pense mais
voilà
rex ne prend pas de majuscule au moins
eux n'avaient pas fait là au moins eux
n'avaient pas fait l'erreur topman
n'avait pas fait l'erreur sur ce coup là
donc rex avec une majuscule mais
attention là où ça devient horrible
c'est vous allez voir ce que c'est
qu'ils appellent un cousin du t-rex
voilà c'est un an kilos d'or il appelle
un an qu'ils osent or un cousin du t-rex
moi je dis à ce niveau là autant appeler
un chat une pelle appeler ça un cousin
du t-rex faut vraiment plus savoir quoi
écrire pour vendre son titre quoi c'est
sais c'est pas assez impressionnant ça
qu'il faut en plus que vous nous invente
y est que c'est un cousin du t-rex enfin
oui un tous les toutes les espèces
vivantes sont cousines à plus ou moins
certain degré mais dans ce cas là je
suis cousin du t-rex aussi quoi le lien
au bout d'un moment
voilà le t-rex il a deux bras deux
jambes deux yeux moi aussi j'ai deux
bras deux jambes deux yeux on annonce
être en commun on est cousin quoi donc
voilà c'est pour ça que c'est important
c'est pour ça que c'est important c'est
important aussi quand on parle de
l'évolution des plumes
donc voici ici à le tout dernier article
sortie à propos de l'évolution des
plumes d'ailleurs je voulais vous en
parler parce que il montre que les
ptérosaures aussi avaient des plumes
donc voilà l'article en question qui
nous présente donc le premier
ptérosaures retrouvait avec des plumes
en du moins des choses qu'on peut
qualifier comme étant des plumes parce
qu'il y avait déjà eu un autre petit
rauser retrouver si je ne m'abuse au
kazakhstan avec un peu de
de trucs qui ressemblaient à des poils
mais on n'était pas sûr de ce que
c'était là ils ont fait une analyse très
minutieuse des aigus manque qu'on a
retrouvée et donc cédé tégument qui se
branchent vous voyez il ya des
branchements il ya des ramifications et
ses ramifications ça montre que c'est
pseudo plume on va dire ressemble
beaucoup à ce qu'on trouve chez les
poussins voyez les ce qu'on appelle les
plumes de boer
donc ces petites ramifications elle
montre que ces trucs qui ressemblait
finalement à des poêles dans le premier
spécimen du kazakhstan sont ramifié
comme le sont les plumes et donc si on
part du principe que ce sont des plumes
de boer donc voilà cette espèce de deux
choses là qu'il représente ici si on
part du principe que ce sont des plumes
de boer bas ça veut dire que on peut
remonter jusqu'à l'ancêtre commun des
avait métatarse alia c'est-à-dire
l'ancêtre commun des dinosaures et des
ptérosaures pour trouver des plumes des
ya des plumes au moins jusque là donc
les écailles c'est en noir et en
couleurs en gros c'est les plumes et les
différentes couleurs représentent les
différents types de plumes et donc le
truc c'est qu'ils ont utilisé une
inférence bayésienne donc c'est à dire
un truc qui est beaucoup plus efficace
que le maximum de parcimonie un amateur
du rasoir d'occam bonjour le bayer zia
c'est ça marche beaucoup beaucoup mieux
que la parcimonie pour les grands
échantillons et là on a très très gros
échantillons donc pour les jeux de
données complexes n'a pas la parcimonie
ça s'est un peu aux fraises donc on
utilise une inférence bayésienne est
donc là ference bayésienne montre que
étant donné le registre fossile qu'on a
des plumes chez les dinosaures et
notamment ici chez les théropodes et ici
chez les ornithischiens parce qu'il ya
des ornithischiens à plumes un coup
linda drôme et us ici par exemple est un
très bon exemple est aussi le tianyu
longue donc thien hue l'ong qui a un
proche parent de et et redon taurus et
bien étant donné l'occurrence de toutes
ces structures qui ressemble à des
plumes
eh bien on a une très haute probabilité
parce que c'est ce que fait le bayer
bien savoureux construit des
probabilités postérieur eh bien on a une
très haute probabilité que l'ancêtre
commun des ptérosaures et des dinosaures
est rude et plumes et tout ceci en
tenant
compte du fait qu'il y à des dinosaures
pour lequel on est sûr qu'ils avaient
des écailles notamment les sauropodes
voyez ici là on a les sauropodes et on
n'a pas ce que j'en reviens quand même à
notre au centre de cette vidéo et on a
tyrannosaurus tyrannosaurus on leur
présente très souvent avec des plumes
mais pour autant qu'on sache on a des
empreintes de pau et ses empreintes de
pau ont des écailles est arborus c'est
pareil on a des empreintes de peau ses
empreintes de posséder écailles c'est
pas des plumes donc quand on dit les
tyrannosaures avaient des plumes
en fait on parle de hugh tyrannus voyait
que là il ya de la couleur à la base de
l'arbre évolutif des tyrannosauridés des
tyrannosaures aux ide voyez même moi je
fais l'erreur donc à la base de l'arbre
évolutive des tyrannosaures aux ide on a
des tyrannosaures aux ide qui ont des
plumes you tyrannus et dix longues en
sont un parfait exemple
donc vous voyez que dia les
tyrannosaures avait déplu menant les
tyrannosaures aux ide bazot par contre
les tyrannosauridés ceux qui sont
proches de tyrannosaurus rex pour autant
qu'on sache n'en avait pas et ça vient
aussi avec l'idée est ce que est ce que
les tyrannosaures avaient des plumes à
l'état juvénile ça c'est une idée mais
ça sort de nulle part
voilà ya pas d y a pas de preuves ya
rien c'est juste une hypothèse que basé
sur en gros l'ontt au génie récapitule
la phylogénie donc en gros les bébés
tyrannosaure ferai comme les
tyrannosaures aux ide bazzo et les
adultes tyrannosaure font comme les
tyrannosauridés dérivés voilà c'est
juste une hypothèse dans le vent lancé
comme ça
voilà c'est tout l'éternel débat sur oui
ou non les tyrannosaures et est il oui
ou non prédateurs ma tyrannosaurus rex
en tout cas on est sûr que oui c'était
un prédateur voici une vertèbre d'adp
rose or dans laquelle on a retrouvé une
dent et autour de cette dent il ya une
callosités ce qui montre qu'elle a
cicatrisé sept vertèbres donc que la dhr
other était vivant quand il a été
attaqué et à l'intérieur il y a une dent
de tyrannosaure de tyrannosaurus rex
en l'occurrence donc biologiquement
parlant parler de tyrannosaure à la
place de tyrannosaurus des fois ça peut
avoir son importance parce que l'épreuve
de prédation conte à elles sont pour
tyrannosaurus rex uniquement est ce
qu'il vivait en groupe
la réponse est peut-être ben qu'oui
peut-être bac non le seul la seule
preuve qu'on a cédé
empreintes de pas dont on ne sait pas
qui elles appartiennent mais peut-être à
des tyrannosauridés donc deux empreintes
de pas qui appartiennent à deux
tyrannosaure différents côte à côte
donc est ce que ça montre un groupe en
tout cas ça montre un couple et on a une
espèce d'assemblage de morts en masse
d'alberto szohr les allées morts en
masse d'alberto d'or ça peut vouloir
dire qu'il vivait en groupe mais ça
montre surtout que ça montrerait dans ce
cas que les alberto szohr vivait en
groupe
or alberto or ce n'est pas tyrannosaurus
rex c'est un tyrannosauridés mais ce
n'est pas tyrannosaurus rex donc il est
possible qu'ils aient eu des
comportements différents et la
croissance la croissance on peut aussi
en parler donc donc les courbes de
croissance des tyrannosauridés et je
vais vous montrer que voilà faire la
distinction entre tyrannosaurus et les
autres tyrannosaure ça a son importance
regarder la courbe de croissance de
tyrannosaurus donc directement mesurées
sur des spécimens de tyrannosaurus rex
et regarder la courbe de croissance de
tous les autres tyrannosauridés voyez
que biologiquement c'est pas la même
chose biologiquement ils peuvent être
très différents c'est tyrannosauridés
même à l'intérieur des tyrannosauridés
parce que si on reprend l'arbre de tout
à l'heure l'arbre phylogénétique
l'alberto or le das plateau d'or et tout
ça ils sont pas loin ils sont pas loin
de tyrannosaurus mais pourtant ils
peuvent avoir des biologies extrêmement
différente donc résumé tyrannosaure à
tyrannosaurus rex ou à tyrannosauridés
ou à tyrannosaur inné ou un tyrannosaure
aux ide sa n'applique pas du tout la
même chose
les plus terrifiantes e1 les espèces
espèce est un nom féminin donc les plus
terrifiants te et là je vais vous
renvoyez on verra pendant la vidéo mais
en gros c'est pas du tout ça le but de
la vidéo c'est pas de vous montrer des
espèces terrifiante donc
donc il ya deux il ya erreur et il ya
mensonge et ensuite de l'histoire pas de
la préhistoire noms de l'histoire non
oui c'est bien connu les tyrannosaures
ont vécu après l'invention de l'écriture
c'est bien connu
du moins c'est ce que disent les
créationnistes a évidemment mais voilà
le
le titre donc et déjà bourré
d'incohérences voilà des espèces mallet
t-rex et mal écrit terrifiante et mal
écrit l histoire haut lieu de la
préhistoire
on va rigoler par toutatis 13 de
digressions c'est le moment de regarder
cette vidéo
cette petite perle ce petit bijou alors
je les ai déjà ouvertes dans un autre
onglet 51000 vu tout de même c'est pas
c'est pas négligeable c'est beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on que ce qu'on fait un
31 mille abonnés donc c'est c'est eux le
goliath c'est nous le david donc notre
esprit est tranquille
n'est ce pas allez c'est parti o la
petite musique de batman la petite
musique de batman de ton enfance
le tyrannosaure rex était un prédateur
impitoyable qui vivait à la fin de la
période du crétacé
jusque là ça va moins de 7 tonnes et ce
à hauteur d'environ 4 m ce prédateur
semer la terreur
n'importe quel animal malchanceux qui le
rencontraient hypothèses raisonnables
il n'est sans doute pas le seul il
existait en fait de nombreuses espèces
similaire qui était aussi terrifiante
nous allons nous embarquer pour un
voyage autour des espèces de t-rex les
plus effrayantes et ont jamais existé
dans la préhistoire
déjà il a corrigé préhistoire par contre
il insiste sur le fait qu'il ya
plusieurs espèces de t-rex numéro 5
numéros 5 et 7 les dinosaures ont
reconnu sans doute le fait d'être proche
du tyrannosaure rex fait de lui un
dinosaure digne de mentionner ses deux
chiennes tyrannus connu aussi sous le
nom de tyrannus 2 hucheng en raison de
cette région hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop ona lalalalala alors atteint le
ca jamais de la vie c'est jugene
tyrannus mais bon ça vous l'aurez
compris je veux dire ça c'est juste un
ya pas de squelette complet deux usines
tyrannus mais ça non plus c'est pas du
chêne tyrannus attendez je vais vous
montrer ce que c'est que duchene
tyrannus zhisheng tyrannus effectivement
c'est ça je suis d'accord avec lui pour
dire que c'est pas le plus connu des
tyrannosaures oups alors déjà faut
arriver à l'écrire correctement ce qui
n'a pas été mon cas zhisheng tyrannus je
vais vous montrer à quoi il ressemble le
spécimen de su chan tyrannus donc la
voyez la photo qui la montre et il est
là donc aller la paix chez directement
sur wikipédia donc si shine tyrannus
avec tous les morceaux manquants ont
reconstruit à partir d'un moulage de
tyrannosaurus vous voyez c'est ce que
c'est ce que cette partie de la légende
veut dire donc tout ça c'est du
tyrannosaurus en fait parce que justin
tyrannus c'est ça qu'on a retrouvée
c'est un morceau du maxillaire
donc vous imaginez de tout ça là le seul
la seule partie qui est vraiment une
chaîne tyrannus c'est ça donc bon
raisonnable raisonnable brian petit
morceau de mandibules distille mais bref
zhisheng tyrannus il n'est pas si bien
connu que ça alors je vais même vous
montrez l'eau lolo type donc le lot type
c'est le spécimen de référence 2 hucheng
tyrannus est le seul pour lequel on peut
être sûr voilà ça c'est le lot type 2 u
sing tyrannus
depuis on a retrouvé d'autres morceaux
qui peuvent être attribuées à la bête
mais globalement on connaît que dalle
zhisheng tyrannus donc
et de toute façon vous pouvez voir que
ça ça n'a rien à voir avec ce qui nous
montre là un à la sas et jeux lire des
petites dents recourbé comme ça en plus
je suis même pas sûr si ça ça doit même
pas être un tyrannosauridés tiens on va
faire un petit truc c'est qu'on va faire
une recherche par google images donc
voilà ce que j'ai fait en fait c'est que
j'ai copié collé l'image dans paint
et puis ensuite j'ai rechargé l'image
dans google images et donc la voix la
voix si les voici les résultats qu il me
sort
bon ça m'a pris un peu de temps avant de
le trouver mais le voilà donc c'est en
fait un allosaure us donc un allosaure
us qui vient du dinosaure nationale
monumenta en amérique du nord donc ça
rien à voir avec un zoug tyrannus rien
du tout donc déjà là il ya erreur sur la
marchandise là en raison de sept régions
de chine où on a trouvé ces fossiles
également tyrannosaure rex ce dinosaure
avaient une taille monstrueuse également
tyrannosaure rex
ça sent la traduction un peu un peu
violente de l'anglais un ca en plus
c'est un das plateau russe s'est pas non
plus un tyrannosaure rex donc pourquoi
pourquoi on a donné trop dur ça m de
hauteur et on se m de longueur ce
tyrannosaure était un prédateur dans
heureux même si on peut dire que son
apparence est similaire à celle du t-rex
on peut affirmer sans doute que ce
dinosaure avec une mandibule plus
prononcé ce qui a amené les experts le
classifier en tant qu'espèce de
tyrannosaure il avait une mandibule plus
prononcé je vous laisse réfléchir à ce
que la notion de mandibules plus
prononcée veut dire vous avez deux
heures une mandibule plus prononcée
c'est c'est du vocabulaire d'école de
d'école maternelle là ce niveau là
numéro quatre numéros 4 déjà le numéro 5
était tellement glorieuse cette liste à
cette position se trouve un dinosaure
considéré comme le tyrannosaure le plus
connu anciennement avec une longitude de
9 m on rencontre le lytro nax le une
longitude une longitude
tu es sûr de ce que tu racontes donc il
a une longitude de 9 mètres une latitude
de combien du coup il est il a un point
gps il a des coordonnées ou est-ce qu'on
peut le trouver goethe est qu'est ce que
tu veux dire avec longitude
c'est même pas une traduction moise il à
ce niveau là c'est juste il ya aucun
effort là il ya eu aucun effort cette
position même s'il n'est pas aussi
populaire que le tyrannosaure elle y
trône axe dinosaures appartenaient à la
même famille deux carnivores qui a fait
du mal rog
ça c'est le fossile de litres onac cela
je suis d'accord que ses dents étaient
robustes et pointu ce qui lui permettait
de couper le sang
de casser les os de ses victimes cette
caractéristique est le sens voilà comme
couper l'eau on coupe le sens de couper
le sang ça veut dire quoi
2 ou 2 où ça sort ça de couper le sang
et or un prédateur mortels même si les
petits si on le compare un t-rex bons
numéros numéro 3 on arrive sur le podium
le beast à iv ressort connu en tant que
bien jouer dehors du bifteck bien joué
non non arrivée à prononcer biscaye et
vers sort du premier coup bien joué je
sais pas combien de fois ici à rien mais
c'est balèze donc buté hier soir là je
suis d'accord
et ça c'est bien le squelette de biscaye
et verseur ce tyrannosaure peut être
considéré comme une espèce énorme non
pas pour sa longueur
mais pour sa hauteur aussi si tu veux
dire salon habitude les restes retrouvés
ce dinosaure pouvaient atteindre jusqu'à
5 mètres de hauteur
c'est plus que pour un tyrannosaure rex
sa caractéristique la plus remarquable
et son ouverture additionnelles autour
de l'oeil qui contient probablement un
sac vert qui éclairait son crâne sac
d'air qui éclaire et son crâne mais
seulement quand il avait une idée
lumineuse
[Rires]
il avait une ouverture supplémentaire
autour de l'oeil
j contenait un sac d'air qui éclaire et
son crâne alors ça c'est balèze c'est
très à l'aise là il ya du bon là alors
bis taiye vers sort je sais pas si je
vais arriver à l'écrire du premier coup
ok c'est bon j'ai réussi et on écrit
skull parce que nous tout ce qu'on veut
c'est le crâne on veut pas toutes vos
tous vos dessins tous pourris donc bis
tv ressort oui alors effectivement il a
cette espèce alors son son oeil est un
peu bizarre effectivement par rapport à
un tyrannosaure rex donc là vous voyez
le
là c'est le trou pour l'oeil lors bits
et effectivement elle est vachement
ronde
cette orbite comparer si vous comparez à
tyrannosaurus tir à nos horus skull
voilà vous allez voir que tyrannosaurus
il a une orbite qui est un peu plus qui
est un peu différente
est-ce qu'on a un crâne voilà ça c'est
le crâne type 1 du spécimen donc il n'y
a pas plus tyrannosaurus et vous voyez
que là on voit l'oeil était ici et là il
ya cette petite avancée osseuse qui est
assez typique des tyrannosauridés et est
donc l'oeil ici est mieux encadré en
fait que chez bis tv ressort ou la voilà
il ya un gros trou donc je pense que
c'est de cette cavité on va dire qu'il
veut parler mais qu'est-ce que ça
éclaire et son crâne mais deux ou de
quoi de qui de quoi
pour que la burqa d'ailleurs à propos de
à propos de crâne un peu mal foutu il ya
rexie donc dans la nuit au muséum il ya
ceux il ya un squelette de dinosaure
voilà si vous vous rappelez du film je
sais pas si vous avez vu le film la nuit
au musée
mais il ya un squelette de tyrannosaure
qui s'appelle rexie et qui est vivant
voilà qui devient vivant la nuit et
alors ce qui est marrant c'est de
comparer justement ce crâne la dorée xi
a un vrai crâne de tyrannosaurus rex
parce que là pour le coup c'est
tyrannosaurus rex donc regarder ça c'est
la narine
je valide ça c'est la faulx sentent
orbitaire bon il y en a deux normalement
chez tyrannosaurus rex mais je valide
alors 6 à celle orbite
non ça ça marche pas ça regardez cette
fausse la la la fausse un peu car hélas
en fait c'est celle là et cette petite
fosse l'a en réalité c'est celle là
donc en fait le tyrannosaure 2
le tyrannosaure dans la nuit au musée en
fait il n'a pas d'oeil
ils ont confondu l'oeil avec la fosse en
théorie terre et vous voyez juste
derrière on a la fosse temporal donc
cette fausse en forme de huit ici voyez
la fosse en forme de huit là ya pas de
doute c'est celle-là a ensuite il ya la
fausse car est directement donc
donc voilà il ya là là on est sur eux ça
aurait pu finir dans l'anatomie pour les
nuls près typiquement bref bis tv
ressort et son crâne éclairé quand il a
des idées lumineuses continuerons ce
dinosaure qui habite l amérique du nord
il ya 75 millions d'années pourrait
rivaliser avec d'autres prédateurs
oui bah encore heureux oui ce serait
dommage numéro deux le terrain tofo nice
nommé le monstre assassin
ce surnom décrire exactement ce qu'était
ce dinosaure un prédateur affamés qui
nécessitait beaucoup de nourriture pour
alimenter son corps de cinq mètres de
large
5 mètres de large de 5 mètres de là donc
tout à l'heure on avait le dinosaure de
9 m de longitude là on a le dinosaure de
5 mètres de large
vous voyez là deux d'un côté de la
hanche à l'autre il ya cinq mètres c'est
bien de montrer aux gens des trucs qui
sont pas connus encore faudrait-il ne
pas dire qu'ils font 5 mètres de large
même si on peut affirmer que sa taille
n'était pas aussi imposante que c'est
les autres tyrannosaure aube à 5 mètres
de large c'est quand même plus que
n'importe quel tyrannosaure on peut
affirmer sans peur de se tromper qu'il
pouvait être plus grand est le numéro un
le dinosaure suivant est considéré comme
l'ancêtre direct du tyrannosaure rex
avec une longueur de 9 mètres et un
poids de 2,5 tonnes
bon alors déjà way l'ancêtre direct de
tyrannosaure rex alors retournons voir
cette petite phylogénie bon enfin une
analyse cladistique par définition ne
vous montrera montrera pas d'ancêtres
direct un d'une espèce à une autre parce
que de toute façon une analyse
cladistique ne peut pas faire ça ne peut
pas vous montrer qui est l'ancêtre de
qui on peux juste vous montrer des
degrés d'apparentement donc là
tyrannosaurus les la seule espèce qui
pourrait éventuellement être candidat à
l'ancestrale it et directe de
tyrannosaurus ce serait arborus mais là
ce serait une énorme erreur puisque
tarbes aux russes a vécu en même temps
que tyrannosaurus donc si tu dis que
tarbes odos russe c'est l'ancêtre de
tyrannosaurus c'est un peu emmerdant
parce que voilà il était contemporain
mais c'est en tout cas le plus proche
parent après après il ya d'autres
espèces north american ici en bleu donc
l'amérique du nord je rappelle enfin
l'amérique du nord mais la côte ouest de
l'amérique du nord
ce que l'amérique du nord était séparé
en deux deux zones biogéographiques très
différentes il n'y avait pas de
tyrannosaure de l'autre côté en amérique
du nord mais à l'est
y'avait pas du tout ou très peu de
il n'y avait pas du tout de
tyrannosauridés voilà vous voyez qu'il
ya de ripd aux eaux russes est
appalaches yôzô russe mais ce ne sont
pas des tyrannosauridés c'est à dire que
ce seront des tyrannosaures mais avec
des grands bras donc les tyrannosaures à
petit bras ils ont vécu exclusivement en
asie et en amérique du nord ouest
bref donc les autres dean les autres
tyrannosaure qui pourrait faire
candidats entre guillemets c'est das
plateau aux russes ou bien vraiment très
loin mais et même là ça marche pas parce
que voyez le il ya un petit
chevauchement entre les deux mais voilà
il ya éventuellement albertosaurus mais
alberto zaurus c'est une famille
différente complètement les albères
taurine et donc ouais là soit il veut
parler de lytro nax mais il en a déjà
parlé soyez veux parler de l'aspect
autorise donc j'imagine qui va nous
parler de l'aspect terrorisme mais vous
voyez que d'aspe thésaurus s'il est
l'ancêtre de quoique ce soit bah c'est
l'ancêtre de ce qu la deûle a en fait
c'est l'ancêtre de l'ensemble
tyrannosaurus tarbes aux eaux russes
donc c'est pour ça que c'est toujours
embêtant de parler d'ancêtres comme ça
on le fait tout le temps je veux dire
c'est pas un souci on le fait absolument
tout le temps de parler de qui est
l'ancêtre de qui parce que c'est
tellement plus simple de parler comme ça
mais c'est vrai que par les danses être
directement c'est toujours embêtant pour
ces raisons là c'est la raison
principale étant que l'analyse
cladistique qui est le meilleur moyen
qu'on est jusqu'à présent de
reconstituer les liens de parenté
l'analyse cladistique de toute façon ne
nous dit jamais qui est l'ancêtre de qui
c'est
par défaut elle ne peut pas c'est dans
les réglages en fait de l'analyse à
cette position
ould aspect taurus évidemment voilà
c'était d'aspe d'ossau d'aspe tout avec
ses petites cornes dessus des yeux pers
prédateurs très caractéristique l'été
dont sommet de la chaîne alimentaire
dans les victimes se trouvaient
probablement des dinosaures de plus
grande taille de tuchan cette affreuse 0
la zone 0 la zone 0 la zone zéro sur
vingt
c'est la note que vous donnez à la vidéo
le tyrannosaure suivant qui va mais on a
on a on a un plus
on a un plus on a un bonus la zone 0
c'est un bonus air de ce classement
il considérait comme la version
asiatique du tyrannosaure rex ce
tyrannosaures et le tarbes odos
de tarbes aux russes le mieux ces
soignants d'espèces de tokyo j'allais
dire le mieux c'est son nom d'espèce
c'est tarbes aux russes bâtard et là il
nous montre vraiment la photo la
reconstruction d'un tarbais aux russes
mais je crois qu'ils lui pour lequel il
mériterait le plus le nom de bâtard là
mesdames et messieurs le tarn aux eaux
russes gros bâtard à la vache c'est
dégueulasse leuthard bozor était un
superprédateur dans sa zone
parce qu'ils étaient capables de chasser
les dinosaures les plus grands comme le
das plateau d'or comme le temps explique
jose nord mais pardon il était capable
de chasser des dinosaures plus grands
comme le das plateau d'or ça veut dire
qu'il était aussi capable de voler un
parce que tarbes aux russes ils vivaient
en asie comme l'a dit que cette couleur
rouge alors que d'aspe tozeur et en
amérique
ou alors tu as raté une virgule il
manque une virgule dans ta phrase il
pouvait chasser ou allah ou alors faut
il y aurait fallu dire ça autrement
comme le das plateau d'or il pouvait
chasser des dinosaures plus grand mais
voit sa caractéristique principale est
et ses petites mains qui ne comptait que
deux doigts ouais cela pouvait sanvensa
le distingue pas vraiment d'un
tyrannosaure y aurait d'autres
tyrannosaurus rex
donc voila c'était le top man le top
manfra s'est laissé cinq espèces de
t-rex les plus terrifiants te n'en faut
que je le dise terrifiante eu de la
préhistoire
je rappelle si vous voulez voir des
bonnes informations sur le tyrannosaure
tyrannosaurus mais j'arrivais à l'écrire
eh bien vous tapez tyrannosaurus stop
science et on a fait une vidéo dessus on
a fait une vidéo sur le tyrannosaurus
rex
une magnifique vidéo où nous avons
interviewé un spécialiste le docteur
jean le loeuff qui a écrit son bouquin
t-rex superstar donc voilà je vous
invite à aller voir notre vidéo sur le
t-rex où il ya plein d'informations
beaucoup plus sérieuse j'ai envie de
dire sur le t-rex voilà je ne fais pas
que cracher sur les gens qui
font les choses mal on fait aussi des
choses bien des fois merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi et à très bientôt sur
stop science